الاضواء في البيت لم يعد بحاجه الى من
يضغط على الزرب حتى الى من يوجد في داخل
البيت الفضل في ذلك يعود الانترنت الاشياء
الذي رافق الجيل الرابع من الانترنت اما
الجيل الخامس
فسينقلنا ببساطه الى مستوى اخر اجراء
العمليات الجراحيه مثلا عن بعد شبكه
الانترنت
مثل العديد من التقنيات الحديثه ولدت في
مخابر التقنيات العسكريه قبل ان تعمم بعد
عقودا على المجالات المدنيه الحال تغير
اليوم الجيوش بعثت تتعلم من التكنولوجيا
المدنيه التي فاقت فاعليتها ثرى سنه
الجيوش الاكثر تقدما بل هو باقل التكاليف
وشواهد على ذلك كثيره مشاهدينا مايكروسوفت
دعمت الامن السيبراني لهم ماسك قدم محطات
انترنت اوكرانيا عبر الاقمار الصناعيه
ستار
لينكولوجيا سمحا بوصولها الى سريعين
الشباب حتى في الدول الفقيره لكن للقصه
جانب سلبي ايضا تقنيات حديثه وقعت في يد
الارهابيين مليشيات الحوثي في اليمن مثلا
استخدمت الطابعات الثلاثيه الابعاد لصنع
اجزاء من مسيراتها اوكرانيا حاولت اراضيها
قبل الحرب مقرا للعديد من شركات الذكاء
الصناعي الناشئه استخدمت الشبكه نفسها
لتطويل نوع جديد من التقنيات المهجنه
الطبعات الثلاثيه الابعاد استخدمت لصنع
ذيلنا يركب على القنابل اليدويه البسيطه
والتجربه جعلت من مسيرات تباع على انها
العابه الى اهداف الفتاكه دمرت معدات
بالملايين
اطلقت الحرب المستمره في اوكرانيا العنانه
لبعض الابتكارات غير التقليديه في المجال
العسكري والاستثمار في الابتكارات غير
العاديه في التكنولوجيا العسكريه يمكن ان
يتراوح بين الشركات العملاقه مثل لوكد
مارتن او ريسون او من المؤسسات التي
تمولها الحكومه مثل وكاله مشاريع الابحاث
الدفاعيه الامريكيه المتقدمه ضاربه
الجزيره بالملاحظه هو دور شركات
التكنولوجيا الشابه التي شبهت بالاطفال
الصغار في الساحه الابتكار الطائرات بدون
طيار هي مثال على ذلك فالشركه الاصغر مثل
دبرون الامريكيه وانظمه جيرمن
هي بؤره الابتكار السريع الاوكرانيون اذهل
المراقبين العسكريين بالخطوات الجريئه
التي اتخذوها خاصه في المعارك البحريه حين
ارسل وسبعه طائرات بحريه وتسعين مسيرات
تتميز بنظام دفع من ماركه جاسكي كنديه
شهيره الامر الذي يعطي فكره عن مستقبل
هروب البحريه والتكنولوجيا العسكريه ذات
الاستخدام المزدوج